Today is the most significant day in the
history of the NCAA.
The last day on planet earth,
in the United States of America
in college athletics, where name, image,
and likeness laws will
not be on the books.
And kids will be not allowed
to make money off of their
name, image and likeness.
Today's the last day that
amateurism has at least a shadow
meaning in our culture.
Major ruling from the Supreme
court involving the end.
The most seismic change in
college sports happened in 2021
and it's aftershocks are
still ricocheting across the
landscape.
Non-pro athletes getting
paid for use of their name,
image and likeness until last
year banned by the NCAA is now
allowed and it's changing the
face of sports and business
radically.
According to opendorse,
brands spent almost a billion
dollars in the first year of
the new rules and that number
is only going to grow, but
some of the biggest winners,
they may surprise you.
Top female athletes are cashing
in and women's basketball
players are standing center stage.
Your heels. You want
your heels to go down,
His poop stinks.
He took a pre-ride poop.
NIL it really is pretty surreal.
I don't think I really wrapped
my head around the concept
that I am making money,
just doing the thing that I love.
Starting her sophomore year,
Azzi Fudd's already signed deals
with Chipotle,
American Eagle,
and others.
Earning tens of thousands of dollars,
leveraging her on-court
prowess and off-court
social media following.
She's also getting massive investment
from the pro game as well,
becoming one of the first
athletes to sign with Steph
Curry's,
SC30 Inc.
The two even designed a shoe together.
One Steph Curry would wear
during his 2021 NBA finals,
MVP performance.
It's an investment directly
into a future player,
but also the future of women's basketball.
And especially for the women's game,
NIL deals may not only
benefit the students,
but the pro game as well.
Wait, I'm gonna call.
Carly knows everything.
Hey.
Hi, Carly.
I have my TV mounted
on the wall of my room,
and I'm wondering if I'm
moving back into the same room.
Can I just take the TV
off and leave them mount?
Kind of all
the little things that I
said I have too much of.
Azzi Fudd can almost trick you
into thinking she's just
a regular college student.
You can't judge me by
what you see here today.
We just finished our summer session.
So I'm about to move out.
I gotta completely move out
to re-move in to the exact same
apartment.
Starting to stress me out.
I gotta carry this back.
Who's gonna help you move
all the big stuff though?
Oh, well you see, I leave tomorrow.
So I will be probably
pulling an all nighter.
But not if my mom is watching this,
I will be going to sleep early.
And getting my rest.
Don't let a messy dorm room
and procrastination fool you, though.
It's very clear,
very quick that there is
nothing ordinary about her.
Fudd was the class of 2021's number one,
consensus recruit while she
was playing for St.John's
college,
high school out of DC.
Now she's playing for one of
the most storied and winning
programs in any sport in history,
the University of Connecticut Huskies.
The National championship
goes to Connecticut for the fourth
year in a row.
As the dynasty
fulfills its destiny.
Winners of 11 national championships,
producers of Olympians,
and multiple WNBA MVPs,
but Azzi has something
that the trailblazing women
of UConn's past never had:
the opportunity to not
only play basketball,
but get paid for it.
I remember just learning that
you could profit off of your
name and brand,
and I could profit off of Azzi,
the basketball player,
not just Azzi the person,
which I didn't really
understand why you couldn't,
because at least for me like
Azzi the basketball player
is also Azzi the person.
Like basketball is such
a huge role in my life
that I didn't understand why
I wouldn't be able to profit
from it.
It's important to
understand exactly what made
this all possible.
In 2021,
after decades of debate,
lawsuits and legislation,
the NCAA prompted by a unanimous ruling
by the Supreme Court,
finally relented on one of its
longest standing strictures,
that athletes could not in
any way be compensated beyond
scholarships and small
stipends from their schools.
It would only take a
few months before Azzi,
a freshman at the time,
would sign her first
major deal with Chipotle.
Before the freshman even got to play
a game for the Huskies,
she inks her first NIL deal as
a college athlete ambassador
for the magnificent
Mexican restaurant chain.
You are on the leading edge
of something that feels,
for those of us who've
been looking at sports
for a long time,
a very meaningful moment in sports.
The economics are changing.
The role of sports and
society is changing.
We see that from the outside,
you're inside it.
Does it feel momentous to you?
You can tell how important it is,
but at the same time,
this is all I know in
college basketball's NIL,
so I'm still trying to find my way in it,
find my groove and stuff,
but I know how important it
is and kind of like the people
before me paved the way and
set that path for me to be able
to do this and how important
it is for me to be able to take
advantage of this and be able
to continue this on for the
athletes to come.
While colleges and universities
still can't directly
compensate their athletes,
those athletes can legally be
paid by third parties who want
to use their name,
image and likeness,
or NIL.
Azzi,
advised closely by a team led
by her parents and her agents,
has created a portfolio anchored by
relationships with Chipotle,
American Eagle,
sports drink BioSteel,
and SC30.
Brands she already admired
as a successful athlete and
American teenager.
I've been lucky that the deals that
the deals I've been approached
with have been things
that have been really good and things
that I had liked.
Like American Eagle is
one of my favorite brands.
I always wear their jeans.
So it was like one of the
easiest transitions type things.
BioSteel was something that
I hadn't really tried before.
And once I did,
I really liked it.
On the basketball side,
it's impossible to be on UConn's campus
and not feel the weight of history.
Especially when you see
where the team works out.
Officially called the
Werth Family UConn
Basketball Champion Center,
it's a 78,200 square foot complex,
that costs 40 million dollars.
It's most striking feature?
It's split right down the middle
between men's and women's basketball.
Seemingly identical when you walk in,
except,
while the men's team boasts
four national championships,
the women's side has
more than double that.
And that actually
understates their dominance.
The team has gone
undefeated in six seasons
and its players have been
staples on the US Olympic team,
Sue Bird and Diana Taurasi are
only the latest in the line
of superstars,
that began in the early 1990s with
Rebecca Lobo.
The Huskies have featured
12 AP national players
of the year,
including Lobo,
Maya Moore - twice,
Breanna Stewart - three times.
And most recently,
Paige Bueckers.
We'll get to her in a minute.
Banners are,
I mean,
they're overwhelming for me
and I'm not sitting and standing
in your shoes.
What do you take from that personally?
I think it can be seen
for sure as overwhelming,
kind of pressure to live
up to those standards.
But I use it kind of as motivation.
This is our UConn program.
Like, there's no need to
compare ourselves to the past.
We're not those players
that we see on the wall.
We're different players.
Like I'm Azzi.
I'm not Sue Bird
We need to forge our own
path and our own story
in the UConn books
These former UConn stars
help to establish the
UConn team as a product to watch.
Over the last decade,
Media rights moved from
Connecticut Public Television
to SNY and now include Fox Sports.
With game coverage mixed with
behind-the-scenes documentaries,
UConn has become one of the
biggest platforms for women's
basketball.
The UConn women's team is so well known,
that at the moment,
it's arguably a better platform than most,
if not all of the professional
women's teams or even the
WNBA overall.
Well,
I don't think there's any
greater female sports collegiate
brand than the UConn Women's Basketball.
It's on TV.
You can follow those athletes
in a way that if you compare
it to the WNBA,
you don't always get
consistency of coverage,
local or international markets.
You're not always able
to follow those athletes.
Feels so nice to be back.
This is Angela Ruggiero.
She's a former hockey player
and four-time Olympian.
She now runs Sports Innovation Lab.
That's a Boston based company
that uses data science to help
teams and leagues understand
their fans and figure out how
to better engage them.
The future of sports really is
how do you optimize and drive
revenue in these digital spaces,
these digital communities.
So collegiate athletes,
I think,
are gonna really benefit
from the change in the NIL
ecosystem because they're
authentically themselves.
They're using these platforms
already and they're being
entertainers.
Not sure how to work this.
I think it's recording.
Fans of women's sports and
female athletes want more
authenticity.
These fans are dying for not
just the game and the stats and
the scores. They wanna
know what you're doing.
24/7.
They wanna know what these
female athletes think,
what are they wearing?
Who are they dating?
What do they care about?
What are their causes?
And that's gonna build a wave
of support when those athletes
graduate that they'll
hopefully bring to those WNBA
teams.
I think that this is really an
incredible opportunity for me
and all of women's basketball
to be able to benefit
and it's sad knowing that
this is kind of our most
profitable age.
So I think that that's also a big,
an important part of
being able to use NIL
now before going pro.
But dance videos and homemade
Tostino's ads can only take
that mission so far.
Azzi knows that success
on the court comes first,
and allow everything else to follow.
And while UConn has had a storied history,
their last championship
was way back in 2016.
Lucky for her she's playing
with not only just a good friend
and dance partner,
but the best college
player in the country.
Paige Bueckers
Paige "Buckets" Bueckers
is also one of the biggest
college students when it
comes to NIL deals.
Striking the first NCAA athlete deal
with Gatorade,
as well as partnerships
with StockX and Cash App.
And she has been estimated to
potentially bring in a million
dollars in NIL deals.
We do a lot of team
This is your first time horse riding.
Yes.
This is my first one
involving a live animal.
During the last week of
official summer workouts,
Azzi, Paige,
and their teammates finished
their last session and
went over to UConn's horse barn
for some team bonding.
I have an extra large.
Right? So when you're
working with the horses,
you wanna try to stay calm and relaxed.
You're gonna make him anxious.
I'm sorry.
It's typical day in Storrs, Connecticut.
That's what we do when we
don't play basketball,.
Peasants,
farewell.
It was a light moment
before everyone went off
to hang with their families and
get rested up for the season.
A few weeks later,
Bueckers would announce
that her 22-23 season
was over before it even started.
UConn women's basketball,
junior guard,
Paige Beckers,
suffered a torn ACL in
her left knee and will
miss the 2022-23 season.
It's an injury Azzi knows all too well.
Having gone through her
own ACL tear in 2019.
While Paige's absence will test
the team's depth and mettle.
What was on display in Storrs
and apparent in conversations with Azzi
was that she and Bueckers
were intent on using their
increasingly higher profiles,
not just to benefit themselves,
but their entire team.
Bruh,
Paige.
No, you didn't.
Aww, she's so sweet.
Oh, I'm so excited.
In Azzi's case,
that means free Chipotle.
Thanks.
Both Azzi and Paige are conscious
of the inequality that
still exists in NIL,
while all the players
in this room share the
benefit of playing at UConn,
not all can or will get the deals
Azzi and Paige have already signed.
Sophomores. You first, since I catered.
People outside of your
world of actually doing it,
speculate about the consequences
and maybe some of the
unintended consequences of NIL you think,
well,
the really prominent players,
like you are gonna benefit and
then other players are not.
And so maybe there's some
jealousy or envy or whatever.
How do you make sure that it doesn't?
We are very tight.
We're a super close group.
I mean,
you've been to Storrs,
there's not much else to do
besides play basketball and
hang out with each other.
And I think it also is because
that whatever deals we get,
we share with each other.
So I have a deal with
Chipotle and my whole team,
whenever they want Chipotle,
they let me know,
or American Eagle,
they can get whatever they want.
They just let me know.
And I think it goes both ways
with whatever deals other
people have that we're super open and
always willing to share.
I think I'm posting on
Instagram about this.
This would be the last team meal for Azzi
before going on summer break,
and when we next caught up with her,
it would be about as far from
a dorm room in Storrs that you
could possibly get.
Azzi's out in LA this week
to do a commercial shoot
for a new Under Armour shoe,
alongside both Steph and Seth Curry,
along with her is her family,
including her former coaches
and current business screens,
her mom and dad.
We make sure that that one
of us is at everything she
does just to give her that support.
So I've been at a lot of
them still blows my mind,
like,
okay,
wow you look really cute in that outfit,
but it just doesn't like really,
I don't know,
sink in that,
that she's this public figure
for lack of a better word.
The partnership with Curry is
both historic and important.
Well beyond the deal itself.
Azzi was the first woman and the
first college athlete to join
the SC30 brand and has developed
a friendship with Curry.
She fully concedes to initially being
a bit starstruck.
Oh, it's kind of crazy.
I mean,
I try to keep my cool
when I'm working out with
him and then with Seth and stuff on set,
but in my head,
I'm going a little bit crazy.
Yeah.
I first met him at Curry Camp,
right after my freshman
year in high school.
I got invited.
I was one of the first
two girls invited to camp.
And then I was invited
the next year as well.
And then Curry brand
reached out to my agent
at my group and they let me know,
and I was all for it.
I'm working out with
someone that I look up to
and someone that inspires me.
So getting to see firsthand
like him in action,
what he does behind the scenes.
I get to challenge myself and
compete a little bit with him.
It's amazing.
Shooting ads for unreleased apparel
isn't something cameras were welcome into,
but Azzi is also in LA for basketball,
getting private workouts with
Steph Curry's own trainer,
Carl Bergstrom.
Azzi's also been a part of Curry Camps,
including this past
summer in San Francisco.
She also helped design
a shoe for the SC30 line
that Curry himself wore
in an NBA finals game
this past season.
The 2022 Bill Russell NBA finals MVP award
goes to Stephan Curry.
Did you know that on average,
women have 30% less income for retirement?
TIAA was one of the first
brands where I got to use my
platform taught to speak out
about Title IX and retirement
equality.
I think that's definitely
something that I still wanna
continue to do,
but that was big for me because
I'm still trying to figure
out what I stand for and what
I support and things I wanna
be able to support.
She's gotta formulate
her own understanding
and opinion about life.
We all have our own perspectives
and that's what makes us
all unique.
We all have our own
opinions and experiences
and I'm just proud
that she found a level of
comfort to be able to speak on
something that she had no idea existed.
I didn't know existed.
Retirement inequality,
women retire with 30% less
income in retirement than men.
I didn't know that was a thing.
And I think from being a girl-dad,
having her come along has
awakened my senses to things that
my wife has experienced as a player,
that I've seen firsthand,
being a girls' basketball coach,
that the girls endure.
It's been pretty tremendous, honestly.
And as a fellow girl-dad,
Curry's involvement with
an equality campaign was
notable,
but not surprising for Azzi
who said she was drawn to his
brand as much for his
off-the-court persona as his
championship pedigree.
He is a very big family man.
You can see that with his kids,
with his wife.
And I'm huge with my family.
I do everything with them.
They're with me here on this trip.
So I think the family aspect
was huge and just kind of his
personality.
He welcomed me in right away.
Even when I was at camp,
he made me feel part of
that group and special
just being here.
I feel like I'm really part
of this part of this brand,
part of this team,
part of the Curry family.
And I couldn't be more grateful
Kobe Bryant,
forever,
of course remembered as an NBA legend and
rightfully so,
but as a father of four daughters -
Curry's also filled a void that Azzi
and others thought might be
left empty after Kobe Bryant
and his daughter Gigi,
died tragically in a
helicopter crash in 2020.
Bryant had been arguably the
biggest advocate in the world
for the women's game.
And without him,
it was unclear who would carry that torch.
That was kind of a big question
when Kobe died was like,
who was gonna step up and
continue to help fight for women's
basketball and help
kind of raise the game.
And I think Steph is doing
a really good job of trying
inviting women to his camp
and little things like that,
that are helping to elevate women's game.
And this deal is incredible
being not just the first NIL
deal on college athlete,
but also the first female
assigned to his brand.
I don't even really know what word to use.
Describe that feeling when I
first signed it and being here
now,
it means so much.
Azzi's connection to
and reliance on her own family was on
full display in LA,
she'd come to the west coast with her
mom, dad,
and two younger brothers and
her success as a burgeoning
business,
provide some fun perks.
On trips like this.
I love just watching my parents'
reaction because they've
been in the game.
They've always played in
college and they played
professionally.
So seeing their reaction
to kind of where I am,
it's just really funny.
I mean,
my dad loves being around
all these NBA players.
My mom loves seeing all
these high level workouts.
And so I was seeing them happy.
It's really fun.
Hi.
Azzi's parents both played division one
basketball in college
and coached her throughout her youth,
which she credits made her the way she is.
Even if sometimes it's
not so easy to grow up
with two coaches for parents.
Part of the reason that I am the way I am
is because,
well they didn't really compliment much.
So I always had something to work on.
I was always working hard.
I think they did a very good job.
Obviously when I played really bad,
I would hear about that,
but they did a really good
job of separating mom and dad
from coach.
I remember when I was younger,
my dad would take me off to
get ice cream and stuff after
games.
That was something when
we started coaching
and we were very cognizant
of not having that coach role
carry over.
I harbor things a little more.
So sometimes they'd go get
ice cream and I'd be like,
yo,
she sucked.
Why are you getting ice cream?
Doesn't need ice cream.
But then he got us ice cream too, so.
When I started to coach her,
I definitely did not want
to have that contentious
relationship at all.
And so the ice cream thing
became a reminder to me,
a treat to now I get
to go back and be dad.
Katie Fudd played at NC state
and then Georgetown in the late 1990s,
as women's basketball was
starting to gain a bit of
traction.
And the WNBA was in its formative years.
She had to deal with inequalities
that she never wanted her
daughter to face.
When it came time for
Azzi to pick a school,
her mom had a big influence.
When Azzi was getting recruited,
I felt very strongly
about what is the culture.
And when I was a Georgetown,
it was kind of,
it's a men's basketball program
and not really much else
it's evolved since then,
but our practice time was limited
on the court based on when
the men practiced,
or it was just all based around
the men that there's a lot
of schools that she was looking at,
where they had some
storied men's programs,
but how do the players interact?
How does what's the
culture on the campus like?
Let's make sure that we're doing
the right thing by both the
men's and the women's program.
Azzi's parents were able to
go from being her coaches
to fans in the stands,
but now have evolved into her
advisory board on her branding
deals.
I think we spent the
better part of the pandemic
on seminars
and YouTube and listening.
I probably have a four year
degree in and of itself on NIL,
just because we're just
making sure we understood it
as well as we could to help her,
but also connecting with the right people.
And we've been very, very fortunate.
I think the fact that we have
such a great relationship with her,
she trusts us implicitly.
We're not gonna put her
in a situation that one,
she doesn't support the
company or she wants authentic
stuff.
And then we're not gonna put
her in a situation that just
isn't good for her.
Yeah. I like these.
I would definitely say
that this past year,
my freshman year,
it was a little difficult managing.
I mean,
I was really lucky to have
my parents so involved,
so they did a lot of the
background stuff with my agents so
that I wouldn't need to be on
calls and stuff I could focus
on school and basketball.
But I was still trying
to figure my way out,
navigate my first year of
college while also navigating NIL
stuff.
So it did feel a little
overwhelming at times,
but I think we did a
really good job managing.
Now,
looking back on that whole year,
I feel a lot more comfortable.
As the new season starts Azzi's
NIL deals existing and new
will be in the background.
Expectations are always
high at UConn and even more
attention will be on her,
given Buecker's injury.
While new NIL opportunities
grab headlines and attention,
Azzi has a clear focus on what's ahead.
How do you raise your NIL game?
How do you grow it in a way
that's authentically Azzi?
Well,
I think now that I have my first
year kind of under my belt,
I've established my brands
with all these other people,
but I think I need to be able to
establish my own brand more,
like the Azzi brand and post
about myself more as well.
But I think just knowing that
what your priorities are,
that my priorities right now
are basketball and school,
'cause without good grades,
wouldn't be able to play.
And without basketball,
I wouldn't have these
opportunities and these deals.